lastly the interpreter does a lookup for
foil which falls out of the local scope
but is found in the middle scope note
that we're showing this fall through all
in one step but it requires a scan of
the blue context just as before the
interpreter is done with lookups and it
sends the full concatenated string as
output to the logging system this was
also the last line of the function so
the interpreter can jump back out to
where that function was called and
resume processing from there along with
it the focal context will shift out to
what it was before the read context up
until this point the picture of the in
memory contexts on the right has shaped
up to look really similar to the picture
of the lexical scopes on the left the
only difference so far has been that
there are actual values visible here and
in our code of course there are none but
both of them show one blue scope inside
one red scope inside one green scope so
what's the difference between in-memory
scopes and lexical ones this starts to
become clearer when saga runs for the
second time